we're told that if you do not tell a
little girl that she's a little boy
that you're hateful you're bigoted
you're awful you're terrible you're
harming
her you're probably going to kill her
she's probably going to commit suicide
you awful bigot you know there's a flip
side to this story though
as these perverts in the mainstream
media and in politics
and in education are convincing little
kids to castrate themselves and to pump
themselves full of cross-sex hormones
and people are transitioning through
this social contagion
there's an increasing number of people
who are de-transitioning
because they realize that these sickos
these psychos have gotten them to
mutilate their bodies
against their own best interests there
was a tick tock going around so much
of the trans ideology gets spread on
tick tock
it's really short quippy videos that
very often leftist teenagers and young
adults
will just spout nonsense on well this
was the best tick tock i ever saw
it looks like a young man is in the
frame
you know you're kind of like a scrawny
young man but still a young man and
he says hi i've gone by the name matthew
matt for the past three years he's
shaving
in the window right but a few weeks ago
i found god again
okay he hit me out of left field and
completely rocked my world
peep the cool hair my bff did for me
it's like a cross on the back god
reminded me of his love for me
the love i had lost sight of through the
years now he's putting makeup on i
started to see things in a new light
things i hadn't thought about
now you realize wait a second he might
not be a he
little makeup on the eyes then he knit
me together in my mother's womb
exactly the way he wanted me to be
referring to god and because of this
realization i'm de-transitioning and
re-transitioning
into the woman that god intended for me
to be feels weird i'm excited for this
new journey a little anxious too
but through my anxiety i know i have god
by my side
and then you see it's a girl it's a girl
sitting there
pretty girl that's a great feeling
wow isn't that great this is a feel-good
video
this is you actually get a little choked
up about it
because you you see this
person who looks somewhat androgynous in
the beginning of the video
very shortly cropped hair you know
men's clothing no makeup and
not really smiling sort of shaving even
though there's no hair to shave and then
by the end you see oh someone with
makeup looks more like a girl
so it's it is a gen it's a gender
transition just like the left tells us
we should be able to do and yet the left
will not applaud that video
we are told that you should be able to
change your sex however however you
please but something tells me
they're not going to applaud that idea
that a
girl who believed for some period that
she was like a boy you know a tomboy or
something or a
little more masculine that that girl
would then
recognize that wait a second god did
make me
how how he wanted to make me but
actually i am
who i am a girl i am even though maybe i
this is a fallen world so i felt a
little weird but i i am actually a girl
this this argument you sometimes hear
god doesn't make mistakes this was an
argument
in the gay rights movement decades ago
and now it's an argument in the
transgender
movement but it doesn't quite work as
well in the transgender movement right
because if you say
okay god doesn't make mistakes right
you're a girl
well no but i think i'm a boy right but
god doesn't make mistakes
i don't think that the god doesn't make
mistakes is
natural exactly the best argument in a
fallen world because the fact is that
sin and death pervade the world because
of
original sin but if you're going to use
that argument it surely does not work
on this transgender issue
i suspect you're going to see more of
this and i suspect for any parents out
there
who are or teachers out there who are
supporting this
vicious evil ideology of transgenderism
which is
just a rehashing of the same old
gnostic heresies that you saw in
manichaeism
that you saw albigensianism these on
marcianism
there are a lot a lot of isms here folks
going back thousands of years
it's not as i know that we like to think
in this modern world that we're the
first people to ever think of
anything but we're not these smarter
people than you and i
have hashed out these ideas before but
because our education is so degraded now
we do not really have the access
to these thoughts before we make big
mistakes i think you're going to see a
lot of this and i think you're going to
see a lot of resentment
from people who are pushed by perverts
and
idiots into mutilating and destroying
their bodies at a very young age
below the age of consent before they had
developed their faculties of reason
and woe to the parents and the educators
who indulge this kind of insanity
young girls fall for this nonsense
because
the media push radical propaganda
among other the educators as well the
politics as well
if you don't ring that bell right now
you are a racist you are a sexist
and you are endangering hundreds of
millions of americans
am i doing that right i'm trying to be
as persuasive as the mainstream media
are
well that's it you gotta subscribe you
gotta like that's how you'll get
notifications otherwise you're you'll be
the worst person in the world and listen
to me and listen to me
all right enough of my don lemon
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
you